i don't i don't want to hear about
listen we just need to
we just need to get along
we just we need to stop being so
so
forceful and aggressive in our political
maneuvers we need to stop we need to
stop being so cultural here's what i
want to hear about here's what i want to
hear
about donald trump said that the
democrats spied on him when he was a
candidate and when he was
the president
all the squishes laughed at him and they
all went on cnn and they all mocked him
and they all opposed him and then it
turned out it was completely true
clinton associates hillary clinton
associates spied on donald trump at
trump tower at his campaign
and at the executive office of the
president this is a major major crime
we know this from john durham's report
the doj now we have found out that the
biden campaign
has hired the same firm that did the
same spying on donald trump as president
the biden campaign paid this cyber
security firm seems like the opposite of
cyber security 20 000
the only two presidential campaigns that
this firm has ever gotten paid for
or paid by rather are the clinton
campaign and the biden campaign
i want to look into that i i will not
support
a presidential candidate
who does not promise to get to the
bottom of that to look into that yeah
good cut my taxes great i do i want you
to cut my taxes but yeah sure
yeah okay
get some good trade deals
i want to root out this rank political
corruption because our opponents
are running roughshod over our
our political order not just the issues
but the order the institutions the power
centers and we're not doing very much
about it who is still working with this
cyber security firm what campaigns i
want to know the names of those
campaigns
what levels are they at are we talking
about congress are we talking about
senate is joe biden still working with
this campaign i want to find out i want
to subpoena the people who are working
with this campaign i want to find out
what they knew and when they knew it
i want names and i want accountability
the white house is completely
stonewalling
so occasionally you'll have a real
question asked in the white house
briefing room the deputy press secretary
corrine jean-pierre was asked this
question she said no no nothing to say
here la la la go talk to the doj
this news is about a durham
investigation
um does the president have any concerns
about a candidate for president
using computer experts to infiltrate
computer systems
um of competing candidates or even the
president-elect to you for the goal of
creating a narrative is that something
that
that's something i can't speak to from
this podium so i refer you to the
department of justice what was described
in that report monitoring
internet traffic
is is that spying again i can't speak to
that report you i i refer you to
department of justice generally speaking
that with monitoring internet
trafficking my answer so i can change i
refer you to department of justice i
can't speak to that from here
la la la la la talk to the department of
justice la la la la la i can't hear you
okay uh kareem you won't tell us how
about you jenn saki what's going on what
about this huge
probably the most egregious political
scandal in our nation's history you guys
were even working with the firm you got
anything to say about it
do you know if there's still a system
picking up
server data on the eop and if not
when it stopped again i i know you asked
my colleague a few questions about this
the other day uh but i would point you
any questions about this at the
department of justice and then is what
was described in the filing there
monitoring internet traffic is that
generally speaking would that be
considered something
along the lines of spying again i would
point you to the department of justice
same answer they talk to the lawyers
they're workshopping this as they're
sticking to their script okay because
they know that the republicans have
these democrats dead to rights there's a
benefit here for the biden campaign
which is that biden is extremely
unpopular hillary's being floated as a
candidate so i think they're fine to
throw hillary under the bus but they're
implicated too because they worked with
this this firm as well they know
that their views are unpopular they know
that their record is very very unpopular
they've got no good answer on this the
only way that they think that they're
going to win here is by stonewalling
gaslighting and cheating so they're
going to say la la la la stop it stop
pushing stop pushing that's how you know
we are right over the target got to keep
pushing harder i'm glad you like that
clip
if you want to get more clips ring the
bell subscribe get notifications one way
to really guarantee you get
notifications in case our friends here
at big tech
don't send them to you for whatever
reason is to head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you